as vaccines receive approval and become
available to the world the next
questions
are ethical such as who gets the vaccine
first
not only do we have to take into account
which age groups
to prioritize but also which
jobs frontline health workers around the
world are already demanding
better protection
and how should distribution work around
the world
as it stands rich countries are already
preparing infrastructure and buying up
future doses by the billions
but won't that leave poorer countries
already grappling with inadequate
healthcare systems struggling
to secure their own
[Music]
the fair distribution of a coronavirus
vaccine looks set to be one of the major
challenges of the coming months if not
years the world health organization who
we'll hear from
later says the world cannot afford to
get it wrong
but time is running out to prepare a
framework for getting
any vaccine to everyone who needs it
it's a huge achievement for the
scientists at the university of oxford
together with drug maker astrazeneca
they've developed their own coronavirus
vaccine
researchers say it's most effective when
patients receive a half dose
followed by a second full dose a month
later
the developers say it offers several
advantages over competing vaccines
it can be stored at refrigerator
temperatures for more than six months
making it easy to distribute and as
drazenica claims
it can be produced more cheaply than
other vaccines
the company is now seeking emergency use
listing from the world health
organization
it's really excellent to see that the
high efficacy that we're now getting out
of these
trials coupled with the safety uh the
ability to manufacture in large doses
the ability to feed into existing
distribution networks or vaccines that
already
are in place around the world because
all of that together
this vaccine and other vaccines as well
is what's going to really make a
difference we have to get a lot of
people vaccinated
astrazeneca is the third western drug
company to report
success with their coronavirus vaccine
candidates
recently german company biontec in
partnership with pfizer
and us-based company moderna presented
mrna-based covet-19 vaccines
which the companies claim are almost 95
percent effective
vaccines developed by chinese and
russian researchers
also show high reported efficacy some
have already been approved
for emergency use
the next challenge is going to be to get
enough people immunized
fast enough to have an impact on the
virus and that does take time i mean it
simply takes time to manufacture
to get the vaccines distributed and then
to get them into people's arms
um it can't just be done overnight so
the more vaccines we've got the more
doses of each of the vaccines we've got
the easier that's going to be the
question remains
how can the vaccines be distributed in a
fair way without discriminating against
poorer nations
that's the challenge facing the kovit 19
vaccine global access initiative
or kovacs but with industrialized
nations having already secured around
1.2 billion doses for themselves
the task is daunting
well we can now speak to richard mahego
from the world health organization's
immunization and vaccine development
program he joins us
from brazzaville in republic of congo
thanks a lot for being
with us so let's just talk about this
kovacs coalition
for getting a vaccine to the the poorer
countries
are vaccines getting close but the who
says covax is
still something like 4 billion
underfunded
is kovacs going to be ready for this
vaccine
well i think first of all uh
we need to um um clarify that the kovacs
was set up to make sure that um the
developing
countries uh and including the majority
of
african countries can get access to
vaccine at the same time
than the developed world
and it sets quite some ambitious goals
of
at least providing millions of vaccine
doses to
african uh to uh developed countries
uh by the end of uh 2021.
so um uh with the target of fundraising
that
uh the coverts has set for itself to
raise up to two billion dollars by the
end of december
2020 as a first step i think we can say
that
at least um the preliminary data that we
have
showed that that target of two billion
have been rich
which is by itself it's quite something
very positive
in terms of uh um resource mobilization
but yeah and you've got you've got 107
187
countries involved in kovacs already
which is you know
a lot of countries but there's one
notable country that is not involved and
that's
the us i mean can this program succeed
without the world's biggest economy
well i think that has been a constant
debate around around that i think it has
been shown that uh
clearly the uh um uh objective of
at least supplying vaccines to uh
less developed country through that
mechanism can be achieved
because uh if we looked at the number of
countries that have had there to the uh
uh kovacs today we have 189 countries
representing
close to 90 percent of the global
population has
uh supported the initiative so uh
as much as we would have loved the us
the united states of america to join
that uh initiative i think that with
what has been done so far
it's a really a good sign of solidarity
globally
in a supporting country that are less uh
developed
reaching uh uh increa
introducing these uh vaccine at the same
time that the rich one
yeah is there any hope that uh under a
abide in presidency that the us
might get involved
well i think it's it might be a bit
earlier to
predict in which direction that's uh i
will go
but we we do hope that the change in
administration
uh in the united states might uh
of course send a different signal um
and uh the united states can land
this initiative so how confident
is the who that poor nations are going
to be able to get access to the vaccines
they need
well i think nobody can be uh 100 sure
and this has been even raised as you
know last week during the g20
summit that there is a real risk that uh
uh
some of the country particularly in
africa may may not
get the vaccine uh at the same time that
other countries
so um i think we are continuing to uh
push for that advocacy uh and to make
sure that uh
many countries in the region will access
the vaccine
at the same time but there is very
little guarantee
at the moment that that will happen and
i think this is why
we need to continue to do that type of
advocacy
richard mejigo from the world health
organization thanks for joining us on
the covet 19 special
thank you very much my pleasure
and now is the part of the program where
you get to ask the questions you've been
submitting them
through our youtube channel so now let's
put one of them to our science
correspondent
derek williams
is covet 19 now endemic
when i read this question i thought okay
it's time to talk about the elephant in
the room the fact
that despite all of our fondest hopes
this virus
is not going to fizzle out and go away
um
first let's define endemic the way we're
using the word here is in its
epidemiological sense which describes
when an infection is more or less
constantly present
in the background within a specific
population
and geographic region but it also
implies that it's in a kind of
steady state which covert 19 is not at
the moment it's still spreading
fast and furiously in many places all
over the planet
one of two things could happen next when
enough people build up immunity to it
through infection or vaccination uh
covet 19 could become
an endemic disease or it could
just apparently burn itself out and
disappear like sars did
but not that's not gonna happen in other
words
at this point if we could say that the
disease was endemic
we'd actually be farther along the road
towards returning to life as usual
than we are it would mean covet 19 was
no longer
out of control but was a disease we had
tools
to cope with we'll develop those tools
eventually just like we did with aids
and influenza in fact probably a lot
faster but
but wiping the virus out entirely at
this point would take a massive
planet-wide strategy like the one that
wiped out smallpox
and has nearly banished polio but
projects like that take high levels of
cooperation between nations
and and they take time so covet 19 is
going to be with us for the foreseeable
future
but to some extent at least for how long
will depend on us
our science correspondent derek williams
there a vaccine for covet 19
could be just around the corner but how
willing
are people around the world to actually
take it a recent survey published in the
journal nature
show that around 70 of respondents would
take a vaccine when it became available
people in asian countries like china
south korea and japan lead the way in
terms of their readiness to get
vaccinated
while large proportions of some eastern
european countries for example like
poland and hungary
say they don't want it but what about
you would you get vaccinated against
covered 19.
we're taking a survey on both our
twitter account and our youtube channel
that's at
dw underscore scitec or dw news
on youtube log in and let us know if
you'd be willing to take a vaccine when
one becomes
widely available and if not why not
we'll bring you the results
of the survey very soon